was important top years of the united
states marine corps infantry
and then i came back and i went to unlv
got my degree at unov i joined metro
in the year 2000 so this is my 22nd year
serving this community
and it's a true honor of serving this
community so
and then after that i got two graduate
degrees i got my mba and a master's in
management
and then i promoted throughout the ranks
and i've had several assignments
but by far being part of the traffic
bureau
and influencing the traffic safety of
this community has been probably one of
the most important positions i've held
in this uh as in my career with las
vegas metro
so let's get to it let's talk about
impaired driving
last year we were able to reduce
impaired driving
fatalities impaired driving related
fatalities
by almost 54 percent so that actually
increased our ability to save lives
because that's what it's all about
it's about saving lives and so what did
we do about that
what we did is we started increasing our
dui blitzes and you ask
what is a dui blitz so a dui blitz is a
collaborative effort between
all the jurisdictions within clark
county
metro and nhp have the dui strike team
and the dui strength team is a
collaborative effort as they come
together
to go out and identify detect and locate
and apprehend
impaired drivers and so during our dui
blitz we put about
50 to 60 officers and that is their sole
purpose in life
is to find the impaired driver remove
that driver
off the roadway arrest them before they
hurt somebody
and so like i said last year we
increased our dui blitzes from
quarterly to every month and then during
the holiday season starting in october
we increased it to twice a month so we
did about 15 to 16 dui blitzes last year
we made 381 impaired driving arrests
dui arrests and then we also made over a
thousand stops
and then citations about enforcement ray
about
about five or six hundred citations for
that during those dui blitzes
another thing that we did last year is
we increased
our seven day coverage and make sure
that the dui strike team again a
collaborative effort between nhp and las
vegas metro
and that we had seven day coverage and
so we had squads that their sole purpose
was
to go out there and arrest the impaired
driver and so that really worked out for
us
now the dui strike team they're
approaching about 2 700
arrests since they started for over
about two years ago
and so they really have truly had an
impact out there with the impaired
driver
and so that's another thing we've done
other thing that we've done
is with patrol now with patrol there's
several area commands some are more
impacted than others
reference impaired driving and so we
decided to put on
advanced training for patrol and move
try to give them the ability to identify
detect and locate
impaired drivers more frequently and
also made it more relevant
with them and gave them more confidence
so right now we're actually seeing an
increase in dui arrests for this year in
2021
so we're encouraged by that and we're
excited and that hopefully that's also
going to translate into saving lives
because that's what it's all about
is saving lives and increasing the
community membership and
having an opportunity to truly because
it's tragic stories
every week every month we have tragic
stories that come up
when it comes to fatalities so another
thing that we're going to do starting
this quarter
is we're actually working with the city
and the county to
identify the citizens of this community
that have dui
warrants so this is your warning
right now if you have a di dui
warrant please get that warrant squashed
get that off the books get rid of that
warrant
because i have approximately 15
apprehension teams
available to me that are going to go out
and start knocking on doors and we're
going to start arresting
people with dui warrants and that
hopefully in that
opportunity will actually increase our
ability
to make a difference out there and
that's the key
all day long so the last thing i really
want to talk about
is ab10 and ab10 is the new legislation
that is being out
being proposed and it's actually
increasing the vehicler
manslaughter charge from misdemeanor to
gross misdemeanor
so what does that mean so as a
misdemeanor
you can actually get imprisonment for
six months and a thousand dollar fine
change it to a gross misdemeanor will
actually increase it from
almost a year in prison and two thousand
dollars worth of fine
and the key term in the narrative
of the nevada revised statue is a simple
negligence
when it comes to vehicular manslaughter
simple negligence
so it's key that again please drive
safely out there
and when it comes to impaired driving do
not drink and drive it's actually
important that we do do not drink
and drive so let's talk about speeding
all right so speeding
there's challenges with speeding and the
reason why we see these fatalities
is because a lot of our roadways are
speed supportive roadways
and like roadways like fort apache
durango
charleston you name them rampart
they all have potentially a 45 mile per
hour
zone so if you're traveling at 45 miles
per hour
okay there's a difference for your
ability to stop your vehicle
there it takes reactionary time and then
the
ability of the vehicle to stop after you
decide that you need to push the brake
so the reactionary time usually is about
a second and a half
all right so if you're traveling 45
miles per hour you'll actually
travel 99 feet before
you actually start pushing the brake at
45 miles per hour
then add on another 97 feet for your
vehicle the average vehicle to come to a
complete stop
that's 196 feet when it comes to
actually
stopping your vehicle the challenge with
that is
the average intersection in las vegas is
88 feet
so that's twice the size of an
intersection
so if that person who is darting out
into the roadway or if you identify that
you need to stop your vehicle
and if you're not paying attention and
your reactionary time
is slower than what it should be because
you're not fully aware of what you're
doing out there while you're driving
you'll actually increase that distance
and it becomes
dangerous now we have a society that
supports speed speeding
we know that okay and that's why i've
really pushed on my traffic officers my
motor officers
to get out there and enforce speeding as
much as possible
so let's add on to the numbers right
there if we decide
that you're going 60 miles per hour in a
45 mile per hour zone
that actually increases your stopping
ability of your vehicle with reaction
and the vehicle to 304 feet
that is a football field to come to a
stop now why do i bring that up
the reason why i bring that up is
because a lot of our roadways have
curves a lot of our roadways have the
elevation changes
and those are blind spots and sometimes
when people are making those left turns
right in front of that area where that
blind spot might be coming
and if you're going 60 80 100 miles per
hour
that becomes a great challenge for us
you know and the reason why is because
it takes that much time for you to stop
and so we've had several fatalities even
one just yesterday
involving the motorcycle where it was a
simple left turn
by a older gentleman who didn't see the
motorcycle traveling at such a high rate
of speed
and the motorcycle t-boned into the
gentleman
and so we need to slow that down we need
to slow our speeding down and that is
really the main reason why speeding
is a challenge for us and we it really
gives us an opportunity if we would slow
down
then we would make a difference out
there and an impact
about reducing fatalities that we're
talking about in traffic safety
so let's talk about distracted driving
we know that distracted driving
is still an issue with teenagers we can
drive down the roadway and we can see
people
using their cell phones all the time we
make cell phone stops
all the time and so it's important that
you reduce your ability of not being
distracted while you're in the cabin
while you're driving your vehicle and
it's important because
again we go back to the speeding we go
back to reactionary time
if you're looking down and you're taking
that second or two seconds
to read your message or to answer that
call
and if there is a situation that you
need to stop your vehicle before you
collide
you're actually increasing the distance
for your vehicle to be able to stop
and so it becomes a great challenge when
you need to be able to stop your vehicle
so what are some tips reference
distracted driving
let's talk about that so turn off your
phone
as one of the biggest tips that i can
tell you before you start driving just
turn your phone off and just
leave it to the side another thing you
can do is just set your phone to give a
message to anyone that texts you
or decides to call you that hey i'm
driving right now i'll get back to you
later
another idea is that set up a
if you have passengers inside the
vehicle you can have them make the phone
call
you know or pull over park safely
and then make that phone call and that
will help you out there too
use your passengers the most you can
especially if you need the tax or make a
phone call
that's another tip that you can actually
do or
another thing that really is a big deal
about distraction
distracting driving is your pets your
pets are running around the cabin
and everything else and now actually
your full focus about driving is not
there
so it's important to secure your pets
make sure they're not distracting you
from being fully aware of what you're
doing out there on the roadway it's very
important
and then keep the kids safe inside the
car sometimes we're still seeing
kids unsecure inside the car while
you're traveling
so make sure that they're buckled in
they're in the car seats properly
and that they're secure and so you're
not distracted by them
either and that they're in the safest
position possible to survive a wreck
if should it happen it's a porn on that
and the last thing i want to talk about
on distracted driving is red lights
still count
so if you're stopped at a red light and
you're waiting for the light to turn
green
you cannot use your cell phone at that
moment it still it
clarifies it says it's hands-free it has
to be
hands-free and so it's important that
you
understand that if you need to use your
cell phone if you need to get mapping or
directions or anything done
then pull over safely park or do that
stuff before you start driving so it
helps out with the
reducing distracted driving now let's
move on to pedestrian safety
last year we had 40 fatalities that
involve pedestrians out of those 40
fatalities
27 of those fatalities were the error of
the pedestrian
the pedestrian was at fault why because
simple is jaywalking
usually it happens at the you know again
in the middle of the roadway
and they're not going all the way to the
intersection where the crosswalks are
or they're at the crosswalks and they're
not listen they're not paying attention
to the
traffic control devices stuff like that
or they're not waiting because they're
impatient
it's imperative that you actually don't
jaywalk
you use the crosswalks appropriately and
you cross safely
when you're allowed to do so 27
again out of 40 were the error of the
pedestrian
already for 2021 we've had several
involving pedestrians on charleston
maryland parkway boulder highway these
are all roadways that
have traditionally been
a problem for pedestrians and when
they're working on it but
you need to do your part out there and
make sure that you cross
safely so let's talk about some tips
reference pedestrian safety
all right so when you're coming up and
you're at that crosswalk and you're at
that
the intersection you're waiting to cross
and you see that vehicle coming make eye
contact with that vehicle driver
and acknowledge each other all right so
when you see that
you can actually cross safely once they
acknowledge and you see that vehicle
come to a complete stop
another thing is do not run or dart
into the roadway and the reason why i
bring that up is we've had
several where they were darting in and
out traffic and by the time they get to
the nearest lane or wherever the case
might be
that vehicle and that driver did not see
that person darting across at a full
sprint
and they're and they get hit and killed
it's it's a very tragic story
you know and which happens frequently
unfortunately
we just had a fatal where the pedestrian
was starting to go across the street and
darting across
and another pedestrian said don't do
that don't
do that it is unsafe and that pedestrian
unfortunately the victim of that
scenario actually ignored the other
pedestrians of ice
and so again you know there's those
opportunities where you
go to the crosswalks use the
intersections and cross
safely when it comes to think about
holding hands so the young children out
there
and the parents i'm really talking to
the parents right now please
hold the hands of your children all
right and the reason why is because
certain things might distract those
children and then they might want to
dart out into the roadway
and please hold their hands when there's
a lot of traffic
involved and there's some roadways again
the sidewalks are right next
or you might be traveling down a roadway
where there's actually vehicles parked
on
next to the sidewalk and it creates a
blind spot for drivers as they're
driving along
the parked vehicles and so if the kids
dart in between the vehicles there's no
way that driver can see that kid coming
and that becomes a challenge there and
then obey the traffic control devices
unfortunately we've had
scenarios where they were actually in
the crosswalk
but they didn't obey the traffic control
device they decided just across
right away and the people driving making
a left turn they couldn't see them
see them because the a-frame of their
vehicle
and they were impacted and they were
transported and passed away at the
hospital
we had a couple of those too last year
and it's really again i can't i sound
like a broken record but
it's tragic it's a very sad story when
it comes to our community members
and then finally cross safely we had a
scenario
other situations where um
they had a hoodie on they were buried in
their phone
and they decided to start walking and
then when they started walking the
drivers didn't see
them and they were impacted so be
aware as a pedestrian be aware
of your surroundings make acknowledgment
be
cautious around other vehicles as you're
driving because it's
it's your life it really is important
you know and i can't emphasize it more
and then as drivers no know this drivers
when you're coming
up and you see a heavily populated
pedestrian area
or you see children involved then please
slow down take your foot off the brake
or off the pedal
and go on to the brake and understand
that prepare yourself
expect the unexpected because you never
know when that person is going to dart
across or wherever the case might be
if you just slow down that gives you
that opportunity that actually
puts your vehicle in a position that
actually it can break a lot faster
instead of going from pedal to brake so
it's imperative that you expect the
unexpected and so it's again pedestrian
safety
is absolutely critical right now the
office of traffic safety they're
declaring 2020 is probably one of the
worst years ever in fatalities
and the reason why is because in state
nevada it looks like that las vegas
metro was the only jurisdiction
that reduced their fatalities every
other jurisdiction actually
increase in fatalities and that's
frustrating and so
it's imperative that we look at these
things we talked about impaired driving
we talked about pedestrian safety and we
talked about
the elements of speeding and the reason
why you really shouldn't speed
because there's it's just it it just
means
pretty much lives are on the line when
it comes down to it
so some educational opportunities i just
want to say
that if you go to our website our
facebook website
on lvmbd traffic you know especially
parents that have young drivers teenage
drivers go on there and look at
you know connect yourself there because
what we do is we put up the pictures
from the fatalities
it's always a great discussion with your
kids
you know to say hey it's important that
you don't
drive drink and drive that you're always
aware
that you put your devices down that
you're not distracted
you're not speeding you know it's
important with that stuff and if you go
to lvmpd
traffic that gives you that opportunity
a lot of what i discussed today
is on xerofatalitiesmv.com
now that is the website for uh the
office of traffic safety and there's a
lot of resources on there
that any parent can go on there and take
a look at it
and learn from they talk about speeding
they talk about impaired driving they
talk about the six elements that lead up
to fatalities
they've done all the research they they
identify
certain characteristics that are people
that are
involved in usually involved in fatality
accidents
and so if you fall in that
characteristic you might want to see
you know check yourself and understand
that hey
i need to change my driving behavior
because that's what it's all about
you know it's about changing driving
behavior that's the question that we try
to ask every day in the traffic bureau
how can i be how can i add value
into saving lives to make it important
what i just did we just had a motor
school start off yesterday and what i
emphasize to them is that every mortar
school
now moving on we are going to dedicate
it to a fatality victim
and the reason why i did that is because
i want to bring awareness everyday
awareness to the
young motor officers i understand that
they're not out there just writing
citations
they're not just out there trying to
make arrests but they're trying to make
a difference
to save lives because that's what it's
all about it's important
so another uh educational opportunity is
there's apps out there that actually
help you navigational apps are out there
that can help you they can tell you that
you're speeding
they can tell you make you aware of
dangers in the roadway they can actually
tell you when
we're in the area and we're actually
doing enforcement
so those apps are out there i would
encourage you i'm not going to mention
any
particular ones but those that's another
educational opportunity for you to
become a better driver to help
change your behavior and driving now i
want to touch on school zones real quick
some a lot of questions come up about
school zones and how
they um how the lights are still going
you know and so again there's kids that
are coming on their bikes they're
walking to school
and they're picking up their meals and
their food and stuff like that
and they're going back home to do the
virtual learning so that is one reason
the other thing is there's sometimes
parents conferences going on
there's teachers that are coming going
from the elementary schools middle
schools and high schools
and those important that we obey those
laws when those lights are on especially
when the children are out there
it's imperative that now on top of that
the
younger grades of karen garner through
third grade
are actually going back to school in the
beginning of march so
be very aware that that there's going to
be more children out there
out there on the roadways and especially
around the elementary schools so please
do your part
and drive safe and increase the safety
of our community
through traffic safety and that's what
we're talking about today
so it's again it's i'm grateful to be
here with you today
i cover a lot of stuff relatively
quickly because i want to get to the
questioning
and it's again i've served this
community for over you know
this is my 22nd year being a police
officer and it
it's been a true honor because this is
my community i was born and raised here
too so
so on that note i'll take some questions
captain bledsoe
um you mentioned the holidays uh the
super bowl is coming up
is there any special preparations or
enforcement that's going to be going to
be having that
that's a great question so super bowl
weekend on that sunday we actually have
a dui blitz going
and we're going to have somewhere around
60 to 70 officers about
40 to 50 traffic officers and we've got
a bunch of patrol squads are going to
help us
nhp is going to be out there other
jurisdictions are going to be out there
and from a certain period of time
throughout the evening we're going to be
valley wide and we're going to be doing
dui
enforcement throughout the valley so
please use your designated drivers
use uber use lyft do whatever you got to
do because you gotta remember
a dui arrest is about ten thousand
fifteen thousand dollars for every dui
arrest
besides all the criminal history that
you obtain and everything else
it to use your uber and lyft or actually
designate driver is somewhere between 15
and 25 dollars
so i want you have a great sunday i want
to have
a safe sunday a super bowl weekend and
please
you know please do not drink and drive
and during that time that's what we're
doing
we're doing a dui blitz on that sunday
uh there's a lot
of state tags a lot of unregistered
vehicles is there any special attention
given to those vehicles
so we're waiting for dmv to move forward
on that and we're still
at that point where it comes to covet
and so we're not
enforcing those areas however we're
looking for other infractions to enforce
if you're out there especially the main
focus is speeding
impaired driving and then distracted
driving of course too
uh what should people do if they see
reckless driving or if they have people
doing burnouts in their neighborhoods
they should call us and the reason why
is because that is a very unsafe
situation
that's another great question so we have
those speeders that over there taking
over the intersections please call us
and we'll send out the nearest patrol
officers we'll get the traffic officers
going over there
and we'll try to slow that down and and
remove that element
because it is it is a form of dangerous
driving out there because they are
speeding
they are taking over the intersections
and we really need to stop that
if you do see a reckless driver you know
we call it 410 on there
if you see a reckless driver please call
us because that might give us an
opportunity to
either catch them in the process
or we follow up later we actually have a
reckless driving project
that we do where if your plate is
actually called in
we actually follow up and we do knocks
at doors
and if it tends to be a teenage driver
then we talk to the parents
if it tends to be somewhere at young
adults and we talk to them
and depending on the situation that's
how we'll move forward on that but we do
have a reckless driving project that we
do
actively as las vegas metro
uh recently south of boulder city there
was a terrible fatal
collision with the vehicle and
bicyclists
could just talk a little bit about that
and also share the road
yeah share the road is important
remember when you see the bike
bikes list on the roadway you're
supposed to move over and give them that
buffer zone that's a safety zone
that's about three to five feet so the
important thing about that and it
it's an absolute tragedy that all those
bicylists
passed away and those are members of our
community and it's affected us all
it's as simple as that it truly has
affected us all because it's a very sad
situation
and these are friends and family members
that are affected by this and
and it impacted us all that's all i can
really say
you know reference that but it's
important that we share the road
and that really falls in distracted
driving you know that
again be aware of your surroundings be
fully engaged
in your driving habits and that's
critical that's absolutely critical
and do not and that kind of leads to
another thing with reference distracted
driving but driving
while you know while you're sleepy
you know while you're you know you're
exhausted
you know please don't do that because
that
slows everything else down i talk about
the reaction time the ability to stop to
maintain the laying
those are all parts of commitment that
you've chosen because driving is a
privilege
you got to understand that driving is a
privilege and you is a collaborative
effort of
all the community together working
together to make sure that we all come
home safely
every night uh it's an old term
defensive driving uh just talk about the
importance of that
and we're all in this together yeah so
defensive driving is again
you're there you're fully engaged you're
making sure that you're not distracted
you've got your cell phone off you're
not
speeding you're not impaired these are
all elements of defensive driving
you're expecting the unexpected you're
anticipating
some people might cut you off whatever
the case might be but you
are engaged and you're trying to make
sure that you drive you're driving
appropriately
for the situation and that's that's the
key really becomes the key of the situa
you know
of the scenario while you're out there
every day be fully engaged in what you
have to do
all right this is outstanding i really
appreciate the questions
i really appreciate the opportunity to
do this today
i i can't emphasize it more i tend to
have to go out to pretty much
every fatal and it
it is quite difficult you know
i ha you know it's just quite quite
difficult
to see the heartache and the family
members and the friends
and they really asked that question how
did this happen
but unfortunately we need a cultural
change we truly need a cultural change
because we drive under the impression
that
we're okay to drive we always say that
hey i'm okay to drive
or we say hey nothing ever will happen
to me
or you know stuff like that and it is
true that bad things do happen to good
people
and that's what the heart of traffic
safety